time once again for our pet of the week
segment this time with the city of
Henderson and its animal shelter
Danielle is here with Wynonna now you'll
notice Danielle's on the ground with
Winona who's very excited to be here
Danielle tell us about Wynonna Wynonna
is a two-year-old spayed female bully
mix her biggest issue is she actually
loves everybody
um and so getting her to stay in one
place and not want to visit everybody on
set has been very difficult yes but
she's hyper but she's very friendly she
just she went like you say she wants to
meet everybody yes yeah she really does
she just wants love and attention that's
what she craves most most dogs don't we
all want a little love and attention
humans canines were all the same and
just overall the shelter we know so many
of them are so filled unfortunately with
animals right now what is it like right
now in Henderson yeah right now on a
weekly basis we
overcrowded within just two or three
days so it's super important for the
public right now if you're missing your
animal the police check the shelters
come and reclaim make sure your
microchip information is up to date and
if you've ever thought about adopting
you can't get a better time than now and
Winona needs a good home I wonder who's
been there for a couple of months you
were saying so let's go get Winona a
good home thanks again coming in once
again from the city of Henderson Animal
Shelter and pet of the week
Winona is just very very friendly and
needs a place with a lot of room to roam
if you're interested in adopting Wynonna
you can call the phone number on your
screen for the Henderson Animal Shelter
267-4970 or just head to the city of
Henderson's website cityofhenderson.com